all of these women say they've been
raped in the last two months there's
almost no support for survivors of
sexual violence in this camp near the
city of Goma so they counsel each other
most of the people here fled as the M23
armed group Advanced through masisi
territory
Claudia not her real name says she was
going to collect firewood with a group
of women and girls when they ran into
armed men wearing military uniforms
they tied me to a tree and I was raped
by each of them the first the second the
third and then the fourth the others
were raped by other men one of the girls
in our group didn't survive she was too
small she died during the rape we spent
two days being raped by those men
Claudia says she doesn't know which
armed group her attackers belong to
Congo's Army is accused of backing armed
groups in its fight against M23 M23 is
widely understood to be backed by
neighboring Rwanda both governments deny
supporting the groups in spite of
overwhelming evidence
M23 has seized swathes of territory from
the government forces over the last nine
months
people ran away from their homes and
their Farms up in the hills because it
was no longer safe but life down here in
the camp comes with many other problems
whole families have been scattered
people are sharing shelters with
complete strangers they've been left
traumatized and vulnerable
Claudia says it took her weeks to
finally reach the camp then she says she
was raped Again by a man who attacked
her in her tent
she says it's the survivors group that's
helped her feel like life is still worth
living
Florence boike started it
we first met her last year after she was
forced from her home
she's been helping people in the camps
ever since
she has time for everyone who stops to
talk or ask for help
she says she's recorded more than 120
reports of rape from new arrivals this
year
the majority of them were raised by M23
when their villagers were attacked
others who hid in the bush were raped by
fighters from other armed groups and
some also on their way here by people
who are out of the control will listen
to them and encourage them we do
whatever we can and give them what
little we have
they have almost nothing a small shelter
and a handful of donated medicines
some of the survivors told us they have
infections injuries or severe pain
but they say just being listened to
helps
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera bulengo
Democratic Republic of Congo